all right let's take a look at the HBO
headlines new releases this week and
Winnie the Pooh's in theaters everywhere
great cast we need the Pooh back on the
big screen for the first time in a long
long time John Cleese is one of the
voices in the film Jim Cummings is the
name you may not know but he does Winnie
the Pooh it's a remarkable recreation of
that voice
Craig Ferguson also stars and then
there's a tiny little independent film
called Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part 2 this one might be hard to
find but I heard a ship in Port I've
heard it's worth seeking out if you can
try to find one of your local theaters
that is showing Harry Potter our
theatres and major cities will be caring
yeah Daniel Radcliffe of course ray
Fiennes Alan Rickman I'm not mistaken
you went to see that film that I did
I've seen it it is it's great it ends
the whole thing very nicely and went on
it was sweet
I roll the tear did you hear me yeah
we've been invested a decade in those
movies and you know when you see the
kids kind of grown up and it was that
was touching and [ __ ] and of course the
most important lesson of Ralph with all
those movies is that friendship and
family and love are the greatest magic
of all yeah yeah I'd rather have real
magic like [ __ ] magic from Satan yeah
whatever whatever comes from I don't
care that would have been an amazing
series of films if it was the exact same
series but every once in a while you saw
him consulting with Lucifer yeah and he
was just like what should we do to stop
all the more in Lucifer's like feed me
another baby soul the [ __ ] Harry
whips a baby to Lucifer
he's jumping down like an apple and [ __ ]
these are Voldemort on you should pick
up that chick Harry Potter and the baby
Eater and there's a new book I'm looking
forward to how amazing would that be to
have JK Rowling as a girlfriend and/or
wife just like that [ __ ] talented and
[ __ ] like that like not only can she
tell you stories in bed yeah but then
she could go write them in the morning
and make a billions of dollars no okay I
want one of them when I'm workers Harry
Potter and the unreliable penis is that
the story she writes the next morning
sometimes he's up sometimes it's down
there was no magic spell that could keep
it hard that's what she'd write the wand
chooses you there's a moment dude like
finally Alan Rickman who's phenomenal
[ __ ] actor he's you like good acting
yeah he plays Snape and Snape finally
kind of gets really he opens a it's like
he gets his storyline kind of gets
cleared up and what and it's a really
touching storyline I hadn't read the
books and I particularly stayed away
from the books on tape version the last
one because I just wanted to go watch
the movie clean and whatnot but if you
if you had the option to go to
audible.com you probably would get the
book well done yes absolutely
they've got them all they've got 85
thousand different titles you can choose
from yeah and Jim Dale I'm not even
[ __ ] around Jim Dale does the not was
the audiobook version right that's all
the voices it's incredible he's like you
he could do a zillion different well
that's not crazy
well he's not quite me okay and to be
just one like I think you want to Grammy
for doing it so you're right he's not
like you he's successful
how dare you sir
how dare you so don't make me show my
Doogie Howser clip again because I will
I'm acting my ass off in that locker
room what are you thinking about ray you
stayed away from the audio books because
you wanted to see the monitor and clean
I had no idea about the Snape storyline
and it is it's really [ __ ] touching
and he has one line one when he's you
know I don't want to spoil anything but
that was five [ __ ] breaks you up but
I thought just to be I mean to credit
I'm not criticizing but this is how I
would have cut it differently and not by
like putting a dick in it or something
but yeah write that one line where he
says you have your mother's eyes and
then they explain it 10 minutes later
and for somebody who didn't know that I
would have flipped it so you get the
explanations that when he says it you're
like wow there would have been a dry eye
in the house yeah but I guess they went
another way that 92 million in one day
way so I guess I guess it worked out for
him but you know Snape Allah said try
not to suck any Dixon the parking lot
somebody would have got pooped on the
middle or Tommy show or donkey is stink
ha marcus
[Music]
you